shifting a little bit onto some of the
incredible work you've done around model
cards i know this also stemmed from this
effort to make models more transparent
and i'm just curious how
how did this particular project come
about and you know where you see it
heading in the future
yeah
so the model cards project first started
at google
i was when i first started i was working
on
things like fairness and what a rigorous
evaluation for fairness would look like
in order to figure out what evaluation
to use you have to have a sense of
the context that the technology will be
used in
who could potentially use it both in
terms of your intended users and
malicious actors
because that really informs the kinds of
things that you want to evaluate through
ethical
and fairness lenses
and so i was working really hard on
building up
these kind of design documents for
how to approach model analyses
and it wasn't getting a lot of pickup
and then
around
i forget the year i want to say it was
late 2017
20 early 2018
i was talking to uh tim neat
who
was at that time someone else in the
field with similar interests to me
and she was talking about this idea of
data sheets where it's a kind of
documentation for
data
based on
her experience
at apple doing engineering stuff where
you tend to have specifications of
hardware
but we don't have something similar for
data and she was just talking about how
crazy that is
and so she had this idea of data sheets
for data set
and it really struck me that by
by having this idea of an artifact
suddenly that's something that people in
tech who are motivated for launches
would care a lot more about so right if
we say you have to produce this artifact
and even further you can launch that and
have it count as a launch then suddenly
people are incentivized to do it
so i thought a lot about taking the work
i was doing and then packaging it
similar to a data sheet to make it more
palatable in the tech world
and so then i was trying to think of
what is like a like not a synonym what's
a comparable word to data sheet that
could be used for models i did want to
do something that was shorter in part
because i was keying on this idea of
launches that people will use and so i
was like well it needs to be shorter so
i guess instead of a sheet it's like a
card
and then data model and so her paper she
was working on at the time
to talk about data sheets was called
data sheets for data sets
and so we ended up calling ours model
cards for model reporting
and then once we had the published paper
like everyone started taking it
seriously like both in terms of
internally at google and then
externally in in the tech world so
yeah i definitely would not have gotten
there if it weren't for tim neat's
brilliance of oh you need an artifact
you know you need to make this like a
standard thing that people want to
produce
right that's genius
yeah
we also decided to call it model cards
because
there were a lot of things at the time
that could be used as words in the
fairness realm like fairness reports or
like transparency reports or whatever
but the more we talked about it the more
that seemed like something that would
soon be dated
i really wanted to have a generic term
that like even if fairness and ethics
was something people didn't care about
anymore the fundamental idea would
persist
so it struck me that like saying model
card as opposed to
some other stuff that came out
afterwards like transparency report like
those didn't catch on as much and i
think in part because they weren't
addressing this need to have it be
something very generic that would then
resonate no matter no matter what you're
working
right so that was also like a little bit
just just the name i think really helped
that is brilliant i've never thought of
that longevity of just the name itself
yeah yeah yeah
very cool i'm curious so where
do you see model cards headed in the
future
yeah so
there's a pretty big barrier to entry uh
for doing model cards in a way that's
well informed by ethics
in part because the people who
need to fill out these things are often
engineers and developers who want to
launch their model
they don't want to sit around and think
about ethics and like write up
documentation relevant
and so part of why i wanted to join
hugging face actually was because it
gave me the opportunity to start
standardizing how these things could be
filled out finding the patterns doing
sort of gap analysis
strengths and weaknesses
and starting to automate as much as we
can
and so one thing i really like about
hugging face is there's a focus on
how to create sort of end-to-end machine
learning development processes that are
as smooth as possible and so
i really wanted to
do something like that with model cards
where you could have something
largely automatically generated as a
function of different questions that are
asked
or even just basics of the model
specification directly
so
i'm working towards and i think other
you know other people in the field are
working towards the ability to have
model cards that are as filled out as
possible and then
separately that are also interactive so
this was one of my last i guess big
projects at google was around creating
interactive cards where for example
you can see
the difference
in the
false negative rate as you move the
decision threshold
so
normally with classification systems you
choose some threshold at which you say
yes or no
it's like 0.7
but in practice you actually want to
vary the decision thresholds in order to
trade off the different kind of errors
but that means having like a static
report
of how well it works uh
isn't actually something that is as
informative as you want it to be because
actually you want to know how well it
works as different decision thresholds
um are chosen and actually theoretically
you could use that to decide what
decision threshold to be using with your
system
and so we created this model card where
you could like interactively change the
decision threshold and see how all the
numbers changed
and moving in that direction of further
automation and
interactivity
i think is definitely the way to go
was brilliant and
i feel like that would be so powerfully
used in the future too just to have
better
awareness about those thrust thresholds
in general
right yeah some people like don't even
know that that's a thing when amazon
first started putting out facial
recognition and facial analysis
technology
it was found that like the gender
classification
disproportionately was bad for
black women
and
amazon sort of responded to that by
saying like oh
this was done using the wrong decision
threshold
and then one of the police agencies
who had been using one of these systems
were asked what decision threshold they
were using and they said oh we're not
using a decision threshold which is like
oh you really don't understand how this
works and you're using this out of the
box with default parameter settings
that's a problem
like minimally having this documentation
brings people aware brings people like
brings people to be aware that
you have some decisions to make with
respect to the various type of
parameters
yeah that is a wild it continues to blow
my mind how often things are released
that haven't been run by these basic
kind of checks and balances yeah
yeah exactly blows my mind i remember
when the pandemic started i wanted to
record a podcast with my friend who's a
black woman and google just released the
google meet record
and so i talked her into i was like
we'll just use that it'll be super easy
and the entire recording is just of me
because it didn't it didn't recognize
when she was speaking
yeah i was so upset i couldn't believe
that was
even possible why didn't you test that
and it's it's the culture right it's
just not it's the people who develop
models often don't care about all those
other things and so they're just getting
out models getting out models and right
they're not tested and they're not
explained
in terms of how they work in part
because no one knows because it hasn't
been tested
and that's so different than everything
else we put out
you know like toys and medicine and cars
right there's all these like strategies
of how you really test this to see if
this works and that just isn't there in
machine learning
in part because it's new so like the
laws and regulations don't exist yet
it's sort of like the wild west or
whatever but yeah that's part of what
we're trying to change by doing things
like model cards and data data sheets
and stuff